هذا وافادت القناه الثالثه عش الاسرائيليه
ان مسؤولين بارزين في اداره بايدن ابلغوا
الاسرائيليين بان احصاءات تشير الى ان
حوالي
150 مدنيا لا يزالون يقتلون يوميا في غزه
واضافت ان مسؤولين بارزين باداره بايدن
وبخوا الاسرائيليين بسبب استمرار ارتفاع
عدد القتلى المدنيين وقالت القناه ان
الامريكيين ابلغوا اسرائيل ان عدد
المدنيين غير الضالعين لا يزال مرتفعا رغم
الانتقال لمرحله اقل كثافه في
الحرب ومعنا من ام الفحم الدكتور مهند
مصطفى الخبير في الشؤون الاسرائيليه يعني
وصل الامر بالامريكي الى ان يتحدث الاعلام
الامريكي عن توبيخ لاداره لحكومه نتنياهو
وان بايدن اغلق الهاتف في وجهه الى اي مدى
يستقبل او كيف س يستقبل او يستقبل نتنياهو
تحديدا مثل هذه الضغوط
الامريكيه نتنياهو اليوم في بيانه
الاعلامي يعني اعطى الجواب هو قال انني
استطيع ان اقول لا للولايات المتحده
الامريكيه ونتنياهو تاريخيا كان يقول لا
للولايات المتحده الامريكيه اذا كان هذا
الامر يخدم مصالحه السياسيه الداخليه في
اسرائيل وفي اعتقادي ان نتنياهو حاليا لا
يبالي بالتوبيخ الامريكي ما دام هنالك
غياب لضغط امريكي حقيقي وجدي على اسرائيل
فيما يتعلق بالحرب على غزه حتى هذه اللحظه
كل الطلبات الامريكيه من اسرائيل اغلبها
تم رفضها من قبل بنيامين نتنياهو وتحديدا
وفي وفي مركزها موضوع النقاش حول اليوم
التالي ما بعد الحرب ولذلك نتنياهو حتى
هذه اللحظه بغياب هذا الضغط الجدي
والحقيقي للولايات المتحده الامريكيه على
اسرائيل فهو يملك الامتياز ان يكون لهم لا
حتى في القضيه الاستراتيجيه الاهم فيما
يتعلق بمكانه السلطه الفلسطينيه في الضفه
الغربيه نتنياهو اليوم صر في بيانه انه ما
دام موجود في الحكم لن تكون هنالك دوله
فلسطينيه ولا سلطه فلسطينيه في قطاع غزه
ولذلك نتنياهو سوف يقول لا
طب قد يصعب على اي سياسه اسرائيليه ان
يزايد عليه هل هذا هذا السقف العالي هو ما
يعول عليه نتنياهو في الاستمرار اولا
كرئيس
للحكومه وبالضرورة
مستقبله السياسي وبين مستقبل الحرب على
قطاع غزه هذا الامر اصبح واضح في خطابه هو
دخل في حالي انه اصبح يعتقد ان اي حديث عن
اي افق سياسي عن اي وقف اطلاق النار في
قطاع غزه هذا معناه نهايه مشواره السياسي
وحياته السياسيه ولك هو يعني نتنياهو لا
لا يحكم اسرائيل وحده هنالك المؤسسه
الامنيه المؤسسه العسكريه هنالك الطبقه
السياسيه التي تحسب ايضا حسابات للولايات
متحده وتثمن هذا هذا الدعم
الامريكي كل هؤلاء يعني عديمو الحيله امام
نتنياهو ورغباته في
الاستمرار بلا شك المؤسسه العسكريه
الاسرائيليه تعلم علم اليقين ان الامن
القومي الاسرائيلي متعلق بالعلاقه مع
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه هنالك في
اقطاب في السياسه الاسرائيليه وحتى في
داخل الحكومه يعني مدركون انه بدون دعم
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه اسرائيل لن
تستطيع الا استمرار في هذه الحرب منذ اكثر
من فتره طويله ولذلك هم الان في خلاف مع
نتنياهو بهذا الشان نتنياهو الان يراهن
على وجود حكومه يمينيه داعمه له هو استطاع
نجح في تثبيت هذه الحكومه في تكتلها حوله
بدون طبعا بيني جانس وجادا ايزنكوت الان
حتى لو خرج جانس وجادا ايزنكوت صحيح ان
الاحتجاج ضده سوف سوف يزداد ولكن حكومته
ما زالت متكتله حكومته اليمينيه لا تلقي
بالا ل اهميه الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
هؤلاء شخصيات ورجال لم ياتوا من عمق
المؤسسه الاسرائيليه لم ياتوا من الدوله
العميقه لم ياتوا من المؤسسه العسكريه مثل
سموتريش وبن كفير بالنسبه لهم الحرب على
غزه هي لتحقيق اهداف ايديولوجيه في النظام
السياسي الاسرائيلي رئيس الحكومه هو
الشخصيه الاكثر نافذه في اسرائيل ولذلك ما
دام نتنياهو يعتمد على هؤلاء وما دام انه
رهينه لهؤلاء وما دام يفكر فقط في مستقبله
السياسي فهو يملك هذا الامتياز في ان يوظف
الحاله القانونيه والدستوريه في اسرائيل
لكي يكون الولايات المتحده لا ويصطدم مع
المؤسسه العسكريه يصطدم مع الدوله العميقه
ويصدم مع النخب السياسيه في اسرائيل التي
لا تزال تعتبر ان دعم الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه هو جزء هام من الامن القومي
الاسرائيلي نتنياهو الان موجود في حاله
ضعف هذا حاله الضعف هذه هي ايضا تفسر حاله
الغفره الولايات المتحده الامريكيه بمعنى
انه ضعيف لذلك هو اكثر متوحش لانه ضعيف
لانه يعلم انه اذا انتهت هذه الحرب انه
اذا استجاب لطلب الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه فيما يتعلق بقطاع غزه فيما
يتعلق بالسلطه الفلسطينيه فيما يتعلق
بالافق السياسي قطاع غزه فان فانه سوف
ينهي حياته السياسيه ولذلك هذا الضعف هو
الذي يعطيه هذه السياسه في محاوله
الاستفراد في القرار فيما يتعلق بالحرب
وحتى فيما يتعلق في الاسرى والرهائن في في
في غزه